on termine ce journal sur une victoire
qui soulage les handbaleuses les
handbaleuses de Chambray-lès-Tours ont
remporté à domicile leur rencontre
contre Dijon 30 à 25 à un match de la
fin de la saison elle se maintiennent
donc à la quatrième place du classement
Elite et se rapproche de la
qualification européenne retour sur ce
match avec Hélène chapelet
pour leur dernier match à domicile les
filles du CTHB avaient à coeur de finir
en beauté devant leur public et ces
choses faites face à Dijon les chants
brésiennes se sont imposées ce mercredi
soir 30 à 25 dans la salle comble de la
Fontaine blanche une issue heureuse
après avoir été menée durant la première
partie de jeu la quatrième place du
championnat est encore à portée de main
tout comme une potentielle qualification
européenne la saison prochaine
une phrase qui nous qui m'anime c'est
tout ce qui n'est pas donné est perdu et
voilà ce soir on a tout donné on a tout
partagé et c'est ça qui a de plus beau
pour moi le résultat bah c'est le
résultat justement de ce qu'on a de ce
qu'elles ont donné et maintenant on va
serrer fort les doigts croisés forts les
doigts pour pour avoir cette cinquième
au moins voir cette quatrième place
ce match c'était aussi l'occasion de
remercier certaines choses qui vont
quitter le club la saison prochaine
comme Nina Burke ou Kimberley Bouchard
il y a des filles qui
font beaucoup et bien sûr il y a des
filles qui va me manquer
beaucoup l'année prochaine c'est atteint
Nida c'est sûr mais
oui c'est ça
on va jouer avec des nouvelles filles et
ça va ça va bien aussi
dernier match du championnat ce samedi
soir à Metz l'actuel leader de la LVE
elle l'attache sera rude mais pas
impossible
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]